and long before social let us flex on
each other we did it by the things we
wore by the things we drove by the
stories we told at the PTA most most
people continue to parent their children
based on what they think other people
think of them not by listening to their
actual children I'm unbelievably humbled
to be speaking at this event just what
an extraordinary collection of people
and I hope I get to say hello to all of
you before I get out of here um what I'm
about to talk about is predicated on the
fact that over the last three to four
years off of a pretty sizable base of
followers engagers on social my
awareness grew exponentially over
platforms that skewed younger and as my
attention on Instagram and YouTube grew
aggressively over these thirty six
months what ended up happening was a lot
of the people that I was interacting
with got younger and younger and younger
what I want to talk about today is
predicated on me reading hundreds of
thousands of direct messages over the
last three years what I want to talk
about today is not predicated on my
opinion it's an observation from one
person one man's point of view it's also
the observation of somebody who is so
deeply grateful for the remarkable way
that I feel that my mother parented me
and my father and the circumstances of
being an immigrant born in Belarus
coming to the United States and going
through that struggle I believe that so
much of what every single person in this
audience cares deeply about trying to
affect and so many of the
characteristics that we are passionate
about whether it's empathy or kindness
or gratitude needs to have a remarkable
conversation with ourselves around a
word called entitlement entitlement is
not privilege entitlements a very
important word for all of us because it
is foundational in the starting point to
all the other things we've been talking
about over the last two days entitlement
is also going to be very difficult for
all of us to talk about in this room
because it means we have to look at
ourselves not look at the people that
were imposing it on over the last three
years I have received
hundreds of thousands of messages from
15 to 25 year-olds telling me variations
of stories of how much they love and
appreciate their parents deeply but deep
down they resent them and/or hate them
so much
because while they continue to take
their unlimited uber from their parents
while they continue to take a brand new
BMW under 17th birthday while they
continued to be thrilled that their
parents bought them their first
apartment in New York City or much
smaller things like a first-class plane
ticket or something in that degree they
inherently deeply understand that they
are a zoo animal and are completely
unprepared to actually live in the world
this is very difficult because so many
like myself come from places where you
start with nothing half this audience
came from the [ __ ] dirt the others
have parents or grandparents that did
this is deep within us that once you
tasted garbage you have no interest in
letting your children taste it this is
not judgment you're looking at a man
who's run two companies now and the
number one vulnerability I've had
running these two companies successfully
is I personally created too much
entitlement with my organizations
because I don't like conflict I struggle
with radical candor I'm a tough guy and
[ __ ] Instagram but in real life I
just want to take all the pressure and
do it myself and put everybody in a
happy place cuz happiness deploys better
success until it overcorrects we have a
whole culture that is disproportionately
judging the youth literally judging the
youth that they [ __ ] parented my
friends for us to look at this and
understand what's actually happening we
have to understand that so many in
today's society and long before social
let us flex on each other we did it by
the things we wore by the things we
drove by the stories we told at the PTA
most most people continue to parent
their children based on what they think
other people think of them not by
listening to their actual children
this is a very important conversation we
cannot get to the path of all the other
talks that we've been listening to
without eliminating entitlement it is
very difficult to be empathetic or
grateful without eliminating entitlement
we must put accountability on a pedestal
we must destroy eighth place trophies
that doesn't mean that we don't admire
effort but results [ __ ] matter in
life my mother gave me so much [ __ ]
self-esteem that it makes some people
not like me
however she equaled that with
uncomfortable amounts of accountability
when I went over for in a baseball game
and struck out four times
it wasn't the son's fault it wasn't my
coach's fault she looked me in the face
and said you [ __ ] sucked it didn't
taste great it must have not been fun
for her to deliver but my deep deep
happiness is predicated on her sucking
out every piece of entitlement out of my
body my deep capacity to be empathetic
and grateful which transforms and what
most people see is somebody who markets
but in the way I navigate my life and
the way that I market to the end
consumer my unbelievable opportunity to
speak in front of this crowd today is
predicated on listening I talk you
listen to my podcast I interrupt every
single person that is on my show because
I've already heard what they said and I
just want to move it along and we don't
[ __ ] edit it seems mean it seems
audacious it's deeply based on listening
we have to start the process of
listening to the youth they're telling
us the answers you just care what your
neighbor thinks about your kid you just
care about what your mother thinks about
your kid you just care about what your
sister thinks about your kid you need to
start listening to your kid when this
little hubbub that popped up about USC
and other colleges this was no surprise
to me there was no shock behind this we
are a mass society predicated on
overreacting to other people's judgment
we are awfully good at judging we are
awfully good at judging we have to start
the conversation around entitlement
entitlements a tricky one it's a tricky
one because it's not a lot of fun for
people that are trying to do good to
really look at it there's a whole lot of
people that clap for Greta's talk and
then act a different way the next day we
all know that the hypocrisy is [ __ ]
heavy some things are really lofty it's
hard to [ __ ] boil the ocean but the
truth is you can absolutely start with
yourself and let me promise you the deep
happiness in perpetuity that you will
have if you start with your child will
change the course of your life I've seen
this up close with my siblings I've seen
this through the eyes of hundreds of
thousands of people who I've talked to
yesterday the resentment is palpable
more importantly they genuinely believe
that you do not believe in them because
you're subsidizing their behavior fake
environments where the seed that led us
to the uncomfortable place were in
predicated an enormous amount of money
and happiness in the macro over the last
70 years and much like in our venture
community where people no longer
actually build businesses but they're
building financial arbitrage machines to
raise capital and spend zero [ __ ]
time caring about their consumer and 100
percent of their time caring about
venture capitalists and press we equally
have a community of parents worried
about what other people think instead of
how their kids feel it is also why the
marketing world is massively audacious
we are entitled to think somebody wants
to watch our [ __ ] video just because
we [ __ ] made it we have to have a
much much deeper conversation about
entitlement and when we do all the other
beautiful words that have been spoken in
the last two days
we'll start to fall into place thank you
[Applause]
[Music]